please switch off mobiles or turn them
to silence
toilets and hand washing facilities are
available
in the fire area
there are there is no one present who's
likely to be able to film or take
photographs so I'm going to skip that
the next
members your voice will be will only be
captured on live stream
when the microphone is switched on so
please remember to switch on your
microphone
when you when you are invited to speak
and switch it off again we're not
speaking
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution
I will ask for a show of hands for and
then against recommendations and will
also ask for a show of hands for those
wishing to abstain from voting
so far so good
it's like a rehearsal isn't it
okay agenda item one apologies for
absence I have apologies for absence
from councilor Julie Gooding and
councilor Chris Stanley
item two non-members attending
there are none
agenda item three
minutes of the meeting held on the 12th
of April 2023
I'm required to say members are the
minutes agreed but I don't believe any
of us were present
are you a present are your marked as
absent according to the minutes
the politics for absence were received
from councilor A.L Williams
you tried to catch me out didn't you
yeah okay
don't try again okay
so my proposal is that we note the
minutes of the meeting on the 12th of
April
2023. is that agreed members can you on
a show of hands please
designers thank you
item four
to receive Declarations of Interest
members are there any Declarations of
Interest
there are none
item five questions or notice from
counselors
there are none
item agenda item six matters referred to
the executive and reports from other
committees
members there I am
agenda item seven
exclusion of the press and the public
members I would like to move a motion
without notice that the press and the
public be excluded from the remaining
business on the grounds that exempt
information is defined in paragraph
three of part one of schedule 12a of the
Local Government Act 1972 would be
disclosed
do I have a secondary
seconded by
councilor new James Newport Mr Newport
practicing still
he's had agreed members to show of hands
please in favor
thank you that's unanimous
I will now ask for the live stream to be
stopped
and I'll pause while the technology
is closed